you write quote we'll start our
Pitchfork tour in this chapter by taking
a brief trip through the history of the
Republican party then in the following
chapters we'll take a Tim's career
tanking Deep dive into America's social
justice movement as you started to talk
about okay so let's go uh what's the
history of the Republican Party
I'm looking at this through my vertical
ladder I'm saying what is this this
familiar story of the Republicans from
the 60s to today what does it look like
through the vertical lens right does it
look different and and and is there is
there an interesting story here that's
been kind of hidden because we're always
looking at the horizontal now the
horizontal story you'll hear people talk
about it and it's they'll say something
like the Republicans have moved farther
and farther to the right
and
um and to me that that's not really true
like it was Trump more right-wing than
Reagan I don't think so I think he's
left actual policy yeah yeah so it's so
we're using this again it's just like
you're calling yourself Centrist but
it's not exactly what you mean even
though it also is yeah
so I again this I was like okay look
this vertical lens helps with other
things let's apply it to the Republicans
and here here's what I saw is I looked
at the 60s
and
I saw an interesting story which I don't
think that you know not everyone's
familiar with like what happened in the
early 60s but in 1960 the Republican
party was very it was a plurality you
had progressives like genuine
Rockefeller you know pretty Progressive
people
um all the way to you know then you had
them you know moderates like Eisenhower
and Dewey and then you go all the way to
the you know farther right you had gold
water and you know what you might call I
I call them the fundamentalists um
and so
it's this interesting plurality right
something we don't have today and what
happened was the the Goldwater
contingent which was the Underdog they
were small right the Eisenhower was the
president
uh or had just been the president and
was it seemed like the moderates were
you know it was that's the he said you
have to be close to the center of the
chess board that's right that's that's
how you maintain power these people were
very far from the center of the
chessboard but they ended up basically
have like a hostile takeover they
conquered their own party and they did
it by breaking all of the kind of
Unwritten rules and Norms so they did
things like they first started with like
the college Republicans which was like
this feeder group that turned in you
know a lot of the politicians started
there and they they went to the election
and they wouldn't let the the current
president the incumbent speak and they
were throwing chairs and they were fist
fights and eventually people gave up and
they just sat there and they sat in the
chair talking for you know their their
got their candidate until everyone
eventually left and then they declared
Victory so they basically they they they
they they came in there there was a
there was a certain set of rules agreed
upon rules and they came in playing the
power games saying well actually
if we do this you won't have the power
you know we have the power to to take it
if we just break all the rules right and
so they did and they won and that became
this hugely influential thing which then
they then they conquered California
through again these these people were
taken aback these you know these these
proper Republican candidates were
appalled by the kind of like you know
the insults that were being hurled to
them and the intimidation in the
building and eventually they ended up in
the National Convention which was called
like the right wing Woodstock it was
like you know the Republican National
Convention in 64 was just they again it
was jeering and they wouldn't let their
moderates so their progressives even
speak and there was racism you know you
know Jackie Robinson was there and he
was a proud Republican and he said that
like he feels like he was a Jew in
Hitler's Germany with the way the blacks
were being treated there and it was
nasty and but what did they do they they
had they had fiery you know plurality
enough to win um and they won they ended
up getting crushed in the general
election and they kind of faded away but
to me I was like what that was an
interesting story I see it as
um I have this character in the book
called The Golem which is a big kind of
a big dumb powerful monster that's the
you know the emergent property of like a
political Echo chamber it's like this
big giant it's stupid but it's powerful
and scary
um and to me I was like a Golem rose up
conquered the party for a second knocked
it on its ass and then
and then faded away and to me when I
looked at the Trump Revolution and a lot
and not just Trump the last 20 years I
see that same lower right that lower
right monster kind of
um
making another charge for it but this
time succeeding and really taking over
the party for a long period of time I
see the same story which is the power
games are being played
um in a situation when it had always
been the government relies on all these
Unwritten rules and Norms to function
but for example you have in 2016 Merrick
Garland gets a gets nominated by Obama
and their Unwritten or Norm says that
when the president nominates a Justice
then you pass them through unless
there's some egregious thing that's what
has happened but they said actually this
is the last year of his presidency and
the people should choose I don't think
we should set a new precedent where you
the president can't nominate people uh
nominate a Supreme Court Justice in the
last year so they they pass the throw
and it ends up being Gorsuch
um and so they they lose that seat now
three years later it's Trump's last year
and it's another election year
and Ginsburg dies and what did they say
they say oh let's keep our president
they said no oh actually we changed our
mind we're going to nominate Amy Barrett
so to me that is classic power games
right that there there's there's no
actual rule in what you're doing is they
had they did technically have the power
to block the nomination then and then
they technically had the power to put
someone and they and they're pretending
there's some principle to it but they're
just extra they're going for the a
short-term Edge at the expense of what
is like the workings of the system in
the long run and then what do the
Democrats have to do in that situation
because both parties have been doing
this is they either can lose now all the
time or they start playing the power
games too and now you have a prisoner's
dilemma where it's like both are end up
doing this thing because and then
everyone ends up worse off the debt
ceiling All these power plays that are
being made with these these holding the
country hostage this is power games and
to me that's what Goldwater was doing in
the 60s but it was a healthier time in a
way because there was this plurality
within the parties reduced some of the
national tribalism and that there wasn't
as much of an appeal to that but today
it's just like do whatever you have to
do to beat the enemies and so I'm seeing
a rise in power games and I talk about
the Republicans because they did a lot
of these things first they have been a
little bit more Regis but both parties
have been doing it over the last 20 30
years can you place uh blame or maybe
there's a different term for it
at uh the subsystems of this so is it
the media is it the politicians like in
the senate in Congress is it Trump so
the leadership is it
um or maybe it's us
human beings uh maybe social media
versus mainstream media is there a sense
of where what is the cause of what is
the symptom it's very complex so Ezra
client is a great book why we're
polarized where he talks about a lot of
this and there's there's some of these
are you know it's really no one's fault
first of all it's the environment has
changed in a bunch of ways you just
mentioned and what happens when you take
human nature which is a constant you put
it into an environment
Behavior comes out the environment is
the independent variable when that
changes the dependent variable the
behavior changes with it right and so
the environment has changed in a lot of
ways so one major one is
it used to for a long time actually the
the the First with the Republicans and
then the Democrats just had a
Stranglehold on Senate on Congress there
was no it was not even competitive the
Democrats for 40 years had the majority
and so therefore it actually isn't a
decent environment to compromise it
because now we can both you know what
you want is Congress people thinking
about their home district and and you
know voting yes on a national policy
because we're going to get a good deal
on it back at home that's actually
healthy as opposed to voting in lockstep
together because this is what the red
party is doing regardless of what's good
for my home District you know an example
is Obamacare you know there were certain
Republican districts that would have
actually officially been benefited by
Obamacare but every Republican voted
against it so and part of the reason is
because it's no longer this obvious
majority every few years it switches
it's a 50 50 thing and that's you know
partially because it's become so we've
been so subsumed with this one National
divide of left versus right that
um that that that that people are not
people or whoever you know they're
voting for the same party for president
uh all the way down the ticket now and
so you have this just kind of 50 50
color war and that's awful for
compromise so there's like 10 of these
things you know that have redistricting
but also it is social media it is you
know I call it hyper charged tribalism
we've you know in the 60s you had kind
of distributed tribalism you had some
people that are worked up about the USSR
right they're National that's what they
care about U.S versus foreign some
people that were saying left versus
right like they today and then other
people that were saying that they were
fighting within the party but today you
don't have that it's it's the the you
have ideological realignment so you kind
of got rid of a lot of the in-party
fighting and then there's hasn't been
that big of a foreign threat not nothing
like the USSR for a long time so you
kind of lost that and what's left is
Justice left versus right thing and so
that's kind of this hypercharged
Whirlpool that subsumes everything and
um and so yeah yeah it's I mean you
people point to Newt Gingrich you know
people like there's certain characters
that enacted policies that stoked this
kind of thing but I I think this is a
much bigger kind of environmental shift